happy Thursday reject nation how y'all
do and glad to see you again if you're
new welcome and if you haven't heard
it's not to Lee Dorian's birthday to die
happily births happy [ __ ] birthday
there you're 21 finally I mean she could
drink already it's a hireling but here
you can also drink now you can also
drink now here and there going to
America in July you can get as drunk as
you want and Ireland I know the legal
drinking age is like 12 so you've been
drinking for like nine years already
good for you anyway she's one of our top
patrons she has a special video request
and we want to make sure to get this up
today because it's her birthday and she
loves these buzz feet on solid videos
and we like talking about them she
requested a lengthy one today the
haunted decks of the Queen Mary oh I
thought this would be fitting since I've
been to the Queen Mary several times
around the Halloween time and so have
you
and I've actually never learned anything
about what makes it haunted or anything
I just like going for the cool mazes and
the Club rave so I don't know anything
about why it's haunted let's find out
people died aboard the ship
you're sleeping enough this week I must
be involved wait for one of the most
haunted places in the world as part of
our ongoing investigation to answer the
question are ghosts real right now we're
sitting in the undoubtedly the creepiest
boat in the world allow me to introduce
you to the Queen Mary
dude the creepiest boat in the world I
mean that's not an unfair statement
would you say right it's a marvel it's a
marvel
apparently this boat is 2 times the size
of the Titanic
two times two times it's true all you
need to know is I was here about 10
years ago and I said never come back and
well here I am you're not a man of your
word you know I will say this is a
beautiful sunset though if there's one
thing I could take solace in and uh
today it's that nice sunset enjoy wine
it's the last one you ever gonna see I
said to vlog in the Queen Mary it's on
YouTube that is I certainly hope none
after what I did last time I was here
what did you do you'll find out
[Music]
what these it goes you mean that you
think there's something about mayor
indeed yeah that's exactly you might be
able to change it yeah I think so you
know when things are so pristine and
beautiful like this but vacant there is
something very unsettling to it I don't
know what it is what do you find
unsettling about this lots of things
that being said let's get into the
history of this boat leave dr. brennan's
actually married the Queen Mary was
completed in the 1930s and embarked on
its inaugural voyage on May 27th 1936
from Southampton England the boat served
as the new benchmark for luxury
containing two cocktail bars two
swimming pools five dining areas and
lounges a grand ballroom and much more
however all that luxury would soon go to
waste during World War two when the ship
was repurposed as a transportation
vessel for troops and planners of war in
fact the ship was so much faster than
enemy modes that it earned the nickname
the great ghost created specifically for
the war you don't think the Greco's is a
pretty cool nickname he was pretty
badass named captain the Gray Ghost tell
that's the Rina bar oh my ship well
she's called the Gray Ghost it was
estimated I carried over 800,000 servers
Wow
in 1947 the ship returned to the Queen
Mary status and in 1965 it was sold to
the city of Long Beach in California
where it is now done British public
community campus the boats is 1200 that
day the system to me recently only
personal history with this ship god I've
told she in this story before but about
10 years ago when I was this is risen it
was 17 years old I visited this ship
with a couple friends I was really
interested in the paranormal but didn't
believe it was a real thing
be back in this room this was the this
was my ghost father again
I returned disappointed to my hotel room
on the boat having a B for which bed
were you on
I was sleeping right here this what we
were hanging on this looks like a Best
Western in the face but I was too scared
to open my eyes and when I finally did
to confront the person I was sleeping
next to my friend Elvin I discovered to
my horror and he was actually fast
asleep and snoring my friend Casey
sought the same turn on so we set up a
camera to try and catch that it's more
to the camera we actually caught if you
look in the footage at the left corner
there's a bag with toothpaste on top of
it you'll never forget that plastic
ziplock bag here I'm getting killed not
voting well considering I didn't even
game or focusing on the wrong side this
for you yeah it's definitely a force of
play there though and what is that
gravity
[Music]
there's always like I've never done it
again and I swore I would never return
to this ship and yet here I sit like a
freakin idiot so I've told you numerous
times that I would love to see something
like that if I just get one experience
like that with definitive proof maybe
tonight's the night I'm feeling lucky
that being said there are quite a few
documented deaths that occurred in the
Queen Mary okay I mean there's more
reported ones so let's revisit a company
in 1936 there at their enemy the first
captain of an a Mary died of a stroke in
his cabin 1949 senior second officer
William stark and accidentally drink
laundry detergent store in the gym
apparently the captain at the time had a
gin bottle in his room he said you know
you could do a good job today go to my
room pour yourself a drink he failed to
mention there was an acid or I've also
heard it was detergent oh this doesn't
taste like burning my tongue
oh by the way Shane I have a bottle of
whiskey in the room for you if you want
to go take forever the most unfortunate
this all occurred at one time as I
mentioned before the Queen Mary served
as a transportation vessel during World
War two that's a lot of a total percent
in 1942 the Queen Mary was being
escorted from New York to Glasgow by
another much smaller vessel called the
HMS carousel the charoset was zigzagging
in front of the Queen Mary to confuse
potentially new boats and German bombers
however the Queen Mary travelling at
twenty-eight point five knots
unexpectedly caught up to the carousel
and consequently collided with the ship
splitting the HMS curse out in 20 times
bigger not just going to cut through
that thing so members of the colors that
were killed instantly on impact
orange despairing into the freezing
water watching as the men who remained
on board sank trapped within the remains
of the vessel and for those left in the
water that didn't die from hypothermia
it is said that the current of the Queen
Mary carried the maid chopping them up
in a propeller do you want protocol the
captain of the Queen Mary Cyril
Illingworth was not able to stop to
rescue the passengers and they push the
board reporting the incident nearby
British destroyers
by the time the British arrived about
two hours later it was too late min-hee
had already died from hypothermia and of
the 430 crew members on board the HMS
Paraiso only 99 survived Wow
claims of the charoset passengers and
the boiler room of the Queen Mary and
some claim that the bow of the ship is a
hot spot due to the fact that it's where
the Queen Mary made contact with the
Caruso
oh there's mazes there are you just
afraid of anything that's right now we
shift yeah this is where the ship struck
the carousel we're in her belly
that's the cargo hold they used to keep
POWs down there I got to be a toy this
is a blur thermal camera
so there's any ghost here but maybe it
would pick up their heat signature look
at you in your usual stupid face
normally I'm against asking or
communicating with ghosts but if I'm
truly going to be actually an
investigator in this I have to right
yeah I called it a [ __ ] I called
it a coward right and I said this whole
ship is [ __ ] I think I'm here to
hurt me
Orion is very angry about that
toothpaste density
[Music]
spirits spirit
show yourself Oh doing but don't be
Bruce Willis from diehard spirit one day
for some ministers well no one ever
found their way down there that day so I
was there by myself and I'm sitting
there chopped amendment the woodwork
mystical and I thought wouldn't it be
weird if somebody responded and lo and
behold just on the other side of the
wall I heard somebody go to spirit and
you could try that
[Music]
[Music]
it's just freakin good again damn camera
cut okay
under alleged s included in the first
class swimming pool one apparition
appears in 1930s clothing and the other
in 1960s there's also reports of a
little boy who fell overboard near the
pool who now Hans the passageway
a little girl named Jackie also reported
to haunt this woman I don't know about
any of this just think it's embarrassing
for them to drown in a pool also with a
wife Garner do your own thing that has
conquered buoyancy they drowned on top
of the ocean in the ocean yeah according
to the ship's current campus during
World War Two club died in a horrific
fashion apparently he was shoved into an
oven by Australian soldiers and
consequently burned to death Australian
soldiers they picked up who did not like
the food took this chef in a instead of
giving him one star on Yelp chop them
into enough him is why they created yeah
[Music]
yeah we are right next to I mean down
the hall is the galley where the kitchen
was
I'm a little unnerved at that the
clanking did come from the kitchen
that doesn't sit super well wow you're
actually admitting to something for once
19 year-old crewman was crushed by door
number 13 an automatically closing door
during a watertight room exposed is
sometimes seen wearing white coverings
it's very confusing it looks like it
would be pretty easy to get crushed this
is just in itself even if this is not
spiritually active look at this place so
there's just a number terrible number
thirteen is this not lubrication
happened under the patient love
controllers to be that bull semen
lubrication Jesus Christ that's fine
I think this is it right here this is
door number 13 strange right here yep I
don't like it I'm gonna get out of that
it is crazy that of all the numbers you
could've gotten stuck in there
and okay now I'm sorry it's here today
hello there is anybody here please show
us a sign make a bang
be nice
no no [ __ ] way down it's clearly just
some machine turning on that's an engine
great probably or a ghost right now
we're talking to the gentleman who got
crushed in this door you're here still
please show yourself
see if this is just like hold some [ __ ]
singing skinning
[Music]
maybe that's it just like a just a light
but it looks like someone looking at
other hotspots on the ship including the
[Music]
sick and those diagnosed with a
contagious disease were kept away from
the other passengers and in some cases
the isolation ward circa summation let's
do this
[Music]
did you look scared - oh my god my
[ __ ] heart I'm with exploding dude
[Music]
let's move on to the final stage of the
investigation spending the night on the
ship we have been given access to the
most haunted cabin on the Queen Mary
cabin beam 3 or 0 it amazed that the
captain - ghost - look at this for the
first you've gotta be
[Music]
No I got sleepy they're all asleep yeah
you're gonna lose your mind yeah I'm
gonna lose my mind of course workers and
have worked on this [ __ ] for decades
stuff like in some cases they never go
in there by themselves and when I told
them that we're sleeping in there they
laughed and told me I was an idiot to my
face well so that's but then shaky water
room and like in turn on by SM in fact
cabin B three four zero has diverged so
many reports of complaints of activity
that was actually shut down and ripped
apart about 25 years ago since uh uh
nobody's been allowed to sleep inside
until tonight where we will attempt to
sleep inside cabin B three four zero for
the first time nearly 25 we've ever
attempted something more idiotic than
this
[Music]
say something
[Music]
I see anything at all tonight that
awakes something I need then I'll join
you and this weird little camp you be me
I'll be you
[Music]
[Music]
when I was
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
of what if somehow tricked me into not
being upset that you're still talking
but I'm gonna go to sleep I'm gonna try
again
[Laughter]
[Music]
what of morning we're still here
I wasn't stabbed to death with a butter
knife the room is clear
and now it's just an empty bare room
appropriate for a sitcom ends it we've
got some fun times you're beautiful the
prodigal son returns
today nothing remains
the Queen Mary is an 80 year old ship
with plenty of rich yet tragic history
are there actually ghosts that inhabit
the halls and tacks of this war abortion
or is that merely part of the narrative
after spending one nearly sleepless
night in the ship I can certainly attest
to the fact that the female may be
haunted but as always the answer will
remain unsolved
so this shows there's gonna be a party
in our room later if you want to nope
nope no stop it this is my machines over
there taking his quad so this whole
series is about them never so I guess
this is learn about stuff hey it's funny
they try to conclude to a point of do
you believe it or do you not believe it
it always ends the same change like
whatever Ryan's like I really perfect
sitcom you know nothing ever changes the
characters reset every week and we do a
new adventure that was one of the
funniest ones we've seen that man even
that's 20 minutes long that was an easy
ass watch because they were so [ __ ]
funny oh yeah oddly of all the ghosts
you know paranormal investigators shows
I've seen as the best watery shows I've
seen their their chemistry together
makes this real easily watchable for me
change the the data right yeah yeah cuz
Shane doesn't ever buy any of this he's
so funny yeah yeah Ryan is an exactly
confident paranormal solver yeah like
I'm scared [ __ ] but I really believe all
that exists they're like tailored specs
but in a different but from BuzzFeed I
don't even know if this if this segment
still going on is it may be shamed I'm
ashamed I wish there would be the last
episode Shane dies and then he lives as
a ghost with Ryan I didn't actually know
any of the the details of what made the
Queen Mary haunted all I ever heard
whatever we would go is you know cause
like they make it just a big Halloween
attraction every year ton of mazes a lot
of performers and they even have a
nightclub and it's just a party time I'd
ever knew any of the details matter of
fact when they were going through the
the ship itself I was like I don't I've
never even been to the hallways where
the hotels are all there I've never done
that and that seems really spooky this
seems like a terrible ship to be on
because people just kept dying on this
ship people just kept
yeah I thought it was gonna be an
incident happen like a Titanic you know
like something was one-time happen and
it's all haunted this is like over the
course over other boats it's a lot of
freak accidents and your outing in the
pool that alone that fact alone would
leave me to believe that in some forms
got bad juju you know yeah they're like
energy is the thing and you know there
is some kind of enchanting something
that makes people people and enough
people die in one place I feel like you
can kind of at least yeah feel the
residual of that somehow no I do just
doing that every when I walked inside
the museum of death like the second you
get in there you're like oh my yeah
different energy and who be married me
mary has its own energy to when you're
walking man they haven't done this show
in quite a while I really hope they
bring it back or something man because
this was awesome and these two together
are freaking hysterical man oh like the
people dying in the pool it's just fun
to see them actually go on location too
because the other ones don't go on
location they just talk about stuff for
the most part that's why I would love to
see them come back because now that it
like this is a YouTube paranormal show
yeah now like it's actually grown you
know for being like those like
informative little nugget videos to
being an actual investigation is pretty
cool and just the balance of both of
their personalities is great because
they're all so comfortable enough to bag
on each other - yeah they have no issue
like insulting each other saying the
f-word to each other you know that
brings such charm as much as the
subjects are always super intriguing and
I love haunted stuff they're the best
part they are so much fun to watch that
that's what yeah that combination what I
loved about businesses every single time
they thought something was going to
happen is always something in the room
something like the light bulb or was it
because it did look like a person and I
was like what were they edited that
sequence is really well done it's just a
wide look at maybe an intention building
then he farted good fart moment there
put that toothpaste moment though you
know I gotta give it to him on that part
because that did look odd the way that
occurred because I do think it goes up
and down it looked like someone picked
it up and threw it down it looks like it
was a toss over like that Shane was like
it's because the gravity of you putting
on the other hand like that's no it
doesn't fall like that yeah cuz he put
someone lightly you didn't like throw it
on there to cause a bounce either they
had the good foresight to rig a video
way back yeah or that's pretty creepy
Ryan just believes too much in the
supernatural and she needs to believe it
at all it makes it so funny together
together they come out with
all right well Natalie Doron my dear
happy birthday to you lovely lovely
friend I hope on your birthday you get
pissed drunk I hope a lot of guys at the
bar buy you a lot of drinks I hope you
get laid tonight that's probably the
most important thing you can do
then I hope in six to nine weeks from
now you discover you're actually
pregnant and you have to raise this baby
and give up your career and just stay at
home
then I hope the man agrees to be in your
life but things don't pan out well nine
months from now then he leaves then you
have the raises kid on your own but you
make this kid grow up to be a really
tough kid but then when he's 15 develops
a fatal disease passes away so you
really just waste 15 years of your life
and I are depressed and it all started
with your 21st birthday I feel like I
just lived a life you could you know
just have a nice night and treat
yourself drop is some might have some
salt bath you know a nice book and then
follow it up with like I just a
Mainliner of arrow episodes instead of
you know letting your future go down a
sad and tragic smell of premature death
and childbirth and whatnot I think mine
sounds a lot more adventurous uh yeah
happy birthday ter not to late birthday
love all right guys well you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time over video of ours is up and you
can go ahead check out our patreon a lot
of exclusive videos on their weekly Q&A
is just a whole bunch of fun